[Music]
click this uh cart boy clip
[Laughter]
i was waiting for it
yeah [ __ ] sucks you seen that cardboard
clip
welcome to a day in the life as a
country club cart boy
some guy just got a diet pepsi and told
me to go [ __ ] myself
you must have seen welcome he must have
seen our our bit is that the line you
said no but that's pretty much just our
exact joke i mean yeah being a car boy i
think that's just his real life
there's a palpable depression it
playback playback
a day in the life as a
country club cart boy
some guy just got a diet pepsi and told
me to go [ __ ] myself
you see like that like abuse behave like
victim behavior how he's like constantly
looking over his shoulder yeah he's not
allowed to have any fun yeah on that job
and he's filming from like
his
life
i don't know i could be exactly dude got
a diet pepsi and told me to go [ __ ]
myself
he could be out there getting [ __ ] faced
with his friends and he's like i'm gonna
do a cart boy
who knows
no i think i believe that he's actually
a car boy he has to be yeah i'm just
saying our joke was exactly this yeah
well
shout out what's his name
definitely can't read that i'm just
calling michael
mule fuel i think mule fuel
shout out mule fuel man you know
uh hope you're all right do a favor if
you reach back out make sure you bring
some dr pepper
and don't ever [ __ ] talk to us again
i'll spit in your tip jar dude
that's what car boys really get
that could be a thanks bro
that could be a solid coating to all do
man
spitting in tip jars yeah
yeah
let's go to jamba juice are these your
tips yeah
let me get a strawberry razzmatazz
please thanks
that'll help you grease it up
damn mean as hell no i meant we we go be
cart boys
that would be really good
hey hey guys
where's the girl
you guys want a drink
you guys thirsty at all it's hot
isn't it we just
we just get
tons of horrible cuts of old men
not if you're serving them
maybe you had a pair of fun bags on you
pair of fun bags yeah we want some milk
you got any of that no
you don't
can i
can i get you a beer or anything i'll
take a jack and coke but i want the
person to bring it to me
uh i want them to have tits
yeah
i'll do a uh
shoot i'll do a crown seven
uh but whoever brings it to me i want to
be able to get him pregnant so
that's what i would prefer
cool so i'm the only one on staff right
now i'll dri i'm fine with water
okay okay do you want a water or
no i'll go right out to that lake and
drink it myself i don't want anything
from you good sir
okay i don't want your filthy little
hands on anything that goes in my body
let alone containing what goes in my
body okay
great yeah go [ __ ] yourself man i will
thank you
is that your tip jar
uh hey fellas this is his tip jar
you don't mind if i i just got a little
dip in
oh god
it's all over some say tip jar it's yeah
right now over here
was that a tip jar
rocky watch this
oh you're getting it all over the count
there's nothing in there anyways
here voice yes but yeah go ahead
i'll be your dip container i'll be your
dip spit jar now that i can get behind
yeah
we ain't paying you though
now if you know anyone with tits tell
them we want some more dip how about
that
[ __ ] hell
dip boy
you're a little dip boy aren't you
cody and noel do uh
problematic old man yeah i'm trying to
think of a good time you know i'll do
grizzly wintergreen
who's the grizzly what who's the grizzly
oh it's just it's it's grizzly
oh
see i don't know that
grizz wintergreen
that's the code i know i'll do we both
just pack
like a double horseshoe and we sit there
and whoever throws up last wins
bro i'm an idiot i like that i thought
wintergreen was like reference to a golf
course
like grizzly meaning like it was like
rough like i thought you were just being
clever with the title no
it's the grizzly winter green i'm an
[ __ ]
you know what that you know what that
would be
hold on i got something for you you
think i could survive even one grizzly
wintergreen i don't think i could do two
no definitely not i don't think i could
right now either
right now you said right now i used to
be able to but if cody has time to train
oh yeah
long cut
hold on i got something for you grizzly
wintergreen
long cut
sounds better when you say it that way
smokeless tobacco addictive
what in the [ __ ] is this
see this [ __ ] is crazy people really
pack weed resin
in their mouth
that's what the [ __ ] that is that is the
scrapings of a college kid's bong yeah
it's like half fiberglass
isn't that crazy is it yes there's
fiberglass and dip so it cuts your lip
open
what so that the
nicotine gets in your bloodstream
what yeah dip is gnarly as [ __ ] that's
why people get mouth cancer from it
what the [ __ ] is anyone doing doing that
it's sick
it gets you a sick buzz
for the buzz ever heard of that for five
seconds jesus christ that literally
could be one room in saw 12.
it's just a [ __ ] can of
grizzly wintergreen put that in your
mouth yeah
oh damn smoky mountain herbal snuff
snuff you know you know actual snuff is
snorting tobacco
oh
cool
it's always got to be through the nose
this is grizzly wintergreen right here
oh you [ __ ]
no this is real this is just a live
stream of bears
that's nuts it's sick right
what are you about you about to say some
dark [ __ ] no no i just thought it was
cool
can we just put this full screen first
sometimes
sometimes i can just share things that i
think are interesting
like not everything has to have a
[ __ ] punch line
yeah you're right yeah does it
no
imagine if someone shot that bear right
there
or some dude
some naked dude jumped in front of the
camera
wiggles dick around sometimes
i can just share things that are cool
salmon while they're hunting salmon
what do you think about this very very
good dick
that's cool i like that with this salmon
how about this salmon
bro i'm still turning it off
get out where'd you turn it off i was
watching that who gives a [ __ ]
look at that waterfall no no no
it's sick it is sick you're right no you
guys are not interested in this and it
pisses me off
good
look at those trout look they're hunting
yeah that's though
i'm just making cody endure this because
now he knows what it feels like to
explain karting to anyone else
this is the feel no it is cool
it is cool
dude the fact that this is live there's
just always bears here yeah hunting to
kill what
to kill
no no no come on no no okay you can take
it off now
it is sick though it is cool and it's
beautiful
i'm still hung up on this fiberglass in
diff
why not just take google that real fast
wanna just take broken glass dip it in
[ __ ] moonshine and just hack open
your lip and then just let it sedate
just let it drip into your
bloodstream directly for an a minute
dude i was talking to somebody
this weekend don't tell me we were
talking about dip because he was like i
used to dip in college and i was like oh
me too not not proud of that
and he was like dude i met some guys
that were
hockey players
who would cut
cut the back of their knee and put dip
in the cut and then
put their outfit oh put their uniform
whatever the [ __ ] uniform whatever pads
on and [ __ ] like yeah and go out and
play
so they didn't have to have it in their
mouth and they didn't have to spit but
it's still got their bloodstream were
they i was like that is gnarliest were
they pros or
i don't think so i think they were just
like college hockey kids hockey players
are a different breed of psycho i know i
mean
you you know that going in because you
know um
they all have the build and the
trajectory that they could be something
else yeah it could be a sales exec could
be something they're like nah i'm gonna
knock out all my [ __ ] teeth yeah and
break all these bones in my body yeah um
and play soggy biscuit with my boys yeah
yeah and then we're uh the memories will
make
um
passing around a piece of a cheez-it by
hitting it off our penises
did you find anything
or is it a myth it looks like it's a
myth it looks like a lot of people
believe it's stupid
i'm so dumb there were a lot of people
who were asking that question though
you know you're literally so dumb you
have to call your parents right now and
tell them to delete all memory of you
yeah
you should have swallowed me mom you
should have gotten rid of me
telling your mom she should have
swallowed you
honey i don't swallow so that's not
possible